did you ever feel in danger
and and and medium or
low it's funny I had more problems at
the probably at the low than I did the
medium but at the medium the only thing
that happened
was an article came out in the newspaper
at when I was at the medium it came out
and
said cuz
they're you know they're still
investigating things so this article
comes out and I'm on the front page of
the St Petersburg times it was about the
politician big article and in the
article it says they interview Millie my
lawyer and she says well when Mr Cox was
being interviewed by the FBI one of the
first things they wanted to know about
was this
politician so she just said Mr Cox was
being interviewed by the FBI so I
immediately get taken into custody and
they put me in the in the shoe that the
hole right for my own protection and I'm
there for like 45 days and then after 45
days they're like Cox what do you what
do you want us to do you want us to ship
you I was like no put me back on the
compound I'm like half the guys here
cooperated and he goes yeah it's more
than half he said but this is this is
the guy from sis which is like their
internal security so that's when he told
you that it's actually much higher
percentage he said but he goes but 90 he
said but 100% of them are lying about it
he said you just came out in the
newspaper I go man I'm not concerned if
you are concerned you got to come
immediately to the Lieutenant's office
and tell us we'll ship you I said okay I
get out there people are giving me like
the looking at me and what's up you know
but I don't have a lot of friends anyway
and I come there to make friends and so
at one point this one guy comes to me
I'm walking in the yard probably two
days later after I get on back on the
compound I'm walking guy comes to me he
has a goatee and he's got a it comes
down here got a skull like a little
skull thing he had he had made Whitted
out of wood or something and uh you know
definitely look scary but so I'm walking
and he stopped he goes hey I've
never talked to these guys I had been
there for a year or so and never talked
to any of these guys they're all like
bikers and you know Aryan Brotherhood
and so I'm like uh yeah what's up he
said Bubba Bubba is their leader he goes
he goes Bubba told me to tell you uh not
to walk the yard he don't want to see
you out in the yard and I went okay I
said well I'm going to walk the yard
tonight um I said and if I get the
kicked out of me then I get the
kicked out of me did you talk back to a
guy with a with a with a wooden skull
hanging off his I did but you know what
it was right in front of the guard shack
and so there's guards in the guard shack
you know they're 20 feet away really you
weren't scared I mean I I I think I just
got numb like I'm not stupid but I'm I'm
walking around I'm you know I was scared
from the moment I got there on if that
makes sense so you get to a point where
you're just numb and you're waiting for
it especially when I got out of the shoe
got out of the shoe I went straight to
my cell laid down couple minutes later
it was locked down they closed the doors
I wake up the next morning I go to cow I
go to my job like it starts all over
again so I was I had a very packed
routine so I didn't spend there although
there's guys everywhere and I'm I'm
thinking at some point I might just be
walking around a guy might walk up and
just smash me in the head but it didn't
happen and it's not the guys aren't
getting stabbed but they've got it
coming I didn't on anybody here I didn't
do anything it's not that on other yards
I might not have gotten smashed but I
didn't get smashed and I'd been there a
while and I taught the real estate class
and everybody wanted to take real estate
take real estate so I think that
insulated me to a degree uh I also had U
um made a few friends there and I I
think they were probably also kind of
putting out the words like bro cut this
guy a break MH so I'm walking across and
I tell the guy I said look man I said
you know and I wasn't rude to him he
wasn't even rude to me
really he said don't walk the yard
anymore BB I didn't want you walk in the
yard I said well listen I'm going to go
to cow and then I'm going to go out
there tonight and walk the yard and if I
get smashed I get smashed I go because I
got 26 years and I cannot walk around
for the next 26 years not going on the
yard I said so I'm going to be there and
then that happens and that happens and
he looked at me he goes man I don't give
a what you do that's what Bubba
told me to tell you he said I told you
and he go I don't give a what you
do and he walked off I went out there
that night with a buddy of mine named
Zach um a guy named John Gordon uh with
my cousin and a couple of his buddies we
walk the track for about an hour Bubba
and a group of his guys stood there and
looked at us and as we walked probably
closest we got to him was 30 or 40 feet
that went on for 30 minutes and then
they kind of broke up and went their
separate ways and you know there was a
couple of times where I would go to the
chow
hall and I would go and I'd be sitting
at a table and Bubba would walk up and
tell the other guys at the table I want
to let you guys know you're he didn't
even call me a snitch he said you're
sitting with a a cooperating witness he
said he said that's how you want to roll
he said you ain't going to be rolling
with us if there's any trouble and then
they all kind of looked at me and they
got got a got their plate and they moved
off he didn't tell me to move and he
could have walked up and said this is a
snitch he didn't do that
Bubba was very respectful um so as
respectful as you could be whatever you
want to say about Bubba he was a
respectful man you ever talk to him
directly never had a conversation with
him so that went on but I mean not when
I say that went I mean like literally
like that's a couple of times he said
the same thing to a guy in line one time
guy came up to me later and said look
man but I'm sorry Mt I he was standing
next to me in line Bubba said something
to him he went like 10 or 15 people back
and stood in line later on he came up to
me m I'm sorry bro but you know B I said
bro I said look I get it we're not
friends don't worry about it and and
here's the
thing